- I'm Steve Pitti.
I'm a professor of ethnicity,
race and migration,
American Studies in histories,
and I'm director of Yale
Center for the study
of Race, Indigeneity and
Transnational Migration,
which has helped us support this event.
The RITM Center at Yale exists
to help develop and draw
attention to urgent work
related to Race, Indigeneity
and Transnational Migration
and we're grateful for
our amazing colleagues
and collaborators, and indeed, all of you.
Let me thank my professor,
Professor Lisa Lowe,
and the organizers of this event
for the gathering.
Let me thank the panelists
and others who travel to be here.
And of course, our center staff,
including Nicole Edwards and Maggie Katz,
who've helped with many
of the behind the scenes logistics
to make all this happen.
Here in this windowless space,
enclosed by cement, and steel, and wood
we're bubbled in
the kind of architectural
membrane it seems to me
that can too easily blind us
to where we actually are.
So, I'll remind you that New Haven
has long been home
to Mohegan Mashantucket
Pequot, Eastern Pequot,
Scattercoke, Golden Hill
Paugussett, Niantic,
Quinnipiac, and other
Algonquin speaking peoples.
And then, we're surrounded
not just in this room,
but out in the rainy outdoors
by patterns of violence,
but also, patterns
of creative survival and
persistence every day.
For me, our location underscores
the importance of corroding
the seemingly impermeable
modernist walls here,
and the Gothic walls of
other university spaces.
We've been looking forward to this event
for a long time.
Thanks so much for coming.
I'll now turn this over
to Elizabeth Hinton, Elizabeth?
- [Male] Woo!
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much, Steve,
for that introduction.
I'd also like to thank you
and the Center for the study
of Race, Indigeneity and
Transnational Migration
for all of your generous support
for this event in particular,
to Nicole Edwards, Maggie Kats,
and the RITM staff for their work
in making arrangements for the visitors.
I also have to give a huge thank you
to my colleague, Lisa Lowe.
- [Male] Woo!
- For really making this possible.
(audience applauds)
And for doing just all the organizing
behind the scenes, and
thank all of you for coming.
We have over 120 other people tuned
in virtually and counting.
So, I just really want to thank all
of you for joining us
for this conversation.
I'm Elizabeth Hinton.
I'm a professor of history
African American studies
and law here at Yale.
I'm the author of "From the War on Poverty
to the War on Crime:
the Making of Mass
Incarceration in America,"
and "America on Fire:
the Untold History of Police Violence
and Black Rebellion Since the 1960s."
And it is such an honor
and a privilege to have the opportunity
to engage with Robin D.G. Kelley,
Derecka Purnell and Garrett Felber,
really among the best thinkers
and activists out there today.
To think collectively about liberation
and how we might create a better world.
It's a conversation that
has increasingly grown more urgent,
even if some of the terms
and the contexts have changed
in the nearly two years
since the murders of Ahmaud
Aubrey, Breonna Taylor,
and George Floyd.
I think, we all really wanna know
where to go from here.
So, we're gonna have a conversation
for about 15 minutes to an hour or so,
and then we'll open it up for questions.
Those of you turning in virtually,
feel free to submit your
questions at any time.
I'll be monitoring the chat or the Q&A,
and maybe I'll throw a
couple in there during
the moderated conversation.
And then, when we open it up there,
you'll see two microphones on either side
of the stage.
Please feel free to come
down and ask questions.
That's really the most exciting part
of the conversation.
And then, after the event,
we encourage you to join
us for a book signing
with any of the authors up here,
but especially Derecka Purnell,
whose book I'll talk about in a second,
is the most recent.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers and claps)
He is excited about this, yeah.
- [Derecka] Thank you.
- And that book signing
was made possible by
one of New Haven's gems,
the independent bookstore,
People Get Ready Book.
So, thank you so much to Lauren
and the People Get Ready team
for making this happen.
All right, let me introduce
our esteemed panelists.
I'll go in order of how they're seated.
So, Garrett Felber,
Garrett and I go way back
to grad school and we were both babies,
but he is...
He organized one
of the most important
conferences on abolition
that has taken place in recent years.
The making and unmaking
mass incarceration,
or MUMI Conference at the University
of Mississippi, where he taught
in the history department until last year.
MUMI, which took place in December, 2019
facilitated across
generational conversation
between students, scholars, and activists,
and it was really amazing.
Derecka and I were both there on a panel
on abolition, so we know.
And it was also (chuckles)
really important
because Garrett brought, Garrett held
an unapologetically
abolitionist conference
in Mississippi.
Felber organizes many, many things,
but among those projects
is study and struggle,
which challenges criminalization
and incarceration in Mississippi
through mutual aid, political education,
and community building.
Felber received his
PhD in American culture
from the University of Michigan
and is the author of
"Those Who Know Don't Say:
the Nation of Islam," "The
Black Freedom Movement
and the Carceral State," and the co-author
of "The Portable Malcolm X Reader
with the late Pulitzer
Prize winning historian,
Manning Marable.
And Felber's currently with us at Yale
as a visiting fellow in American studies
and the Center for the study
of Race Indigeneity and
Transnational Migration,
where he has worked to
complete his next book,
a biography of former political prisoner,
Martin Sostre called,
"We Are All Political Prisoners."
To Garrett's left is Derecka Purnell,
who is this generation's
most galvanizing voice
around abolition.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
- [Elizabeth] Now, we all know it's true.
(audience laughs and claps)
(male mumbles indistinctly)
- Thank you.
(laughs)
- [Elizabeth] She's a triple threat.
She's a grassroots organizer,
she's a lawyer, and she's an author.
Her book, let me just show it all to you
so you will go purchase it,
"Becoming Abolitionists Police Protest
in the Pursuit of Freedom,"
just came out last October.
And once again, is available
for purchase outside.
You can get Derecka Purnell
to sign it for you today.
And in addition to this powerful book,
which everybody needs to read,
and if you're in
my African American history survey class,
you're gonna be reading it.
Purnell's writing has
been published widely,
including in the New York Times,
The Atlantic, The Boston
Review, Teen Vogue,
and Harper's Bizarre.
Purnell received her JD
from Harvard Law School
and has lectured, studied
and strategized around
social movements across
the United States,
the Netherlands, Belgium, South Africa,
the United Kingdom, and Australia.
She is currently a columnist at
The Guardian, a Margaret Burrows fellow
for the social justice
initiatives portal project
at the University of Illinois, Chicago.
And a scholar in residence
at Columbia Law School.
And finally, Robin D.G. Kelley
is the Gary B. Nash
Professor of history at UCLA
and the greatest living
historian in America.
(audience claps and cheers)
(Derecka laughs)
He needs no introduction.
So, I'm just gonna stop there.
No, I'm just kidding.
If I were to properly
introduce Professor Kelley,
who I've known now for over 20 years,
I can't, 20 years.
I'm aging us since I was
a bright eyed, 18 year old at NYU.
I would, I need to take
30 minutes before to get-
- Before that.
- Well, yeah, oh, yeah.
- I went to your house
when you were a kid.
- Yes.
- 'Cause I know your dad.
- But I don't remember you.
(Professor Kelly laughs)
(group laughs)
- Exactly.
- I just remember you from the intro
to black urban studies class.
- Right, right.
(Derecka laughs)
- But anyways, okay,
so Professor Kelly received his PhD
in history from UCLA and has been bringing
us hit after hit ever since
from his articles and
op-eds to his 13 books,
including the groundbreaking
and award-winning "Hammer
and Hoe Alabama Communist," since
the great depression, race, rebels,
culture, politics in
the black working class.
Freedom dreams, the
black radical imagination
and Thelonious Monk, the Life and Times
of an American Original, among others.
And these works have illuminated aspects
of the history of social movements
and capitalist exploitation in the US
and the world, that have
inspired generations
of activists, organizers, and scholars
to struggle for racial
and economic justice.
So, getting to have this conversation
and sit down with the three of you
was really a dream come true for me
and I hope for all of you as well.
So, abolition is a process that
in many ways really begins
in our own minds, right?
In our own understanding of the world
and our political and ethical commitments.
And all of you have been doing this work
for some time and so, I'm wondering
if you could each share with us
how you came to abolition as a politics
and as a practice.
And how you think about
the meaning of abolition,
I guess, how you define abolition.
So, we'll start with Garrett, since he was
introduced first.
- Oh my God, okay.
Hi, everyone, can you hear me okay?
Well, it's such a...
I don't know, I wiggled my way onto
this panel somehow,
and I'm just so grateful
(Robin laughs)
(chuckles) to be here.
And I wanna start by just saying thank you
to all the incarcerated comrades,
who I struggle with and
learn from all the time.
I'm hoping we can transcribe
this conversation and send it to them.
And then also, my co-panelists
who I've learned so much from.
So, most of anything I say helpful today
will come from those folks.
I think, to begin with a definition
of abolition, for me, it's
a revolutionary practice
to create an egalitarian society free
of coercion and domination.
That sort of obviates the need
for police, and prisons, and punishment.
And I emphasize, I think, both revolution
and practice, because I think, one
of the mistakes that we make
is to think of abolition as a set
of sort of beliefs, or an identity.
And it really does us no good
to have people who identify-
- [Elizabeth] Mm-hmm.
- As abolitionists, right?
That doesn't get us free.
So, it's also not a destination.
We don't do things and arrive
at this place in particular.
So, I think it's something we do every day
and we stumble through it.
And I think, experimentation
and creativity is sort of central for me,
to that practice.
Oh, my personal journey to it.
I really was sort of politicized
through history, really, thanks
to Robin's writings in particular.
Freedom dreams, I mean, Derecka writes
about this beautifully
in her book as well.
Freedom dreams for me
was a whole new roadmap to thinking
about radical social movements,
not in terms of success or failure,
but as a sort of collective
dream making process.
And I read that the same year
that I read "Black Study Black Struggle,"
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- And that article, Robin talked
about the classroom not
being a place of love,
and therefore, not a
place of deep critique.
And that really resonated with me
at the time because I was teaching
in a minimum security prison.
We were teaching, learning about
the black radical tradition
and he mentioned study groups.
And I was like, "What is a study group?"
I've only, my encounter
with these radical social movements
was only through university
and college spaces,
which didn't feel like a place
of love, and deep critique,
and accountability.
And I was for the first time
in a prison, encountering that space.
And that was a paradox,
or a contradiction to me,
like why was I encountering this space
of love and commitment within such
a violent place?
So, there was an undergraduate student
at the time, who asked me my thoughts
on abolition and I spouted off
some very uninformed things
about utopianism and it sounds nice,
but how would we ever do...
Like the script that we
all sort of fall into
the first time I think,
we encounter abolition.
And I think, that script tells
us something really
important, a few things,
one of which is that we're all
sort of performing something
that we've been normalized to believe
about the function of prisons,
and punishment in society.
And it's actually very helpful
in organizing to undo them
because we encounter
the same set of beliefs.
You know, what about the murders?
What about the rapists?
It's utopian, how would we
ever create this society?
So, I guess, it didn't take me that long
to sort of get from that place
to believing that prisons shouldn't exist,
and police should not exist.
But I really think the practice
of what that actually looks like beyond
just sort of going around pronouncing
that I believe this thing
is the ongoing work of abolition.
Of every day being in touch
with people inside, figuring out
how to support them and
to dream collectively.
I can maybe talk about
that more throughout,
but I think, so much of the way for me,
the journey through this has been always
in sort of tension and tandem
between the prison and the university.
And it's been really helpful
for me to understand the way
that both of those institutions work
to stop collective dreaming.
Those are institutions that work
to silo us to venerate individual thought
and solitary thought, and
not collective thought
and collective mobilization.
So, for me, that's been
the sort of ongoing work is to figure out
how to collectively dream and understand
the people who
have collectively dreamed before us.
- [Robin] Mm.
- Because we're so often cut off
from all the work that they've done
and that's why I think, freedom dreams
for me was such a touchstone,
because I realized that
we have to understand
that ongoing process
of collective dreaming.
(door creaks open)
(panelists chatter indistinctly)
Oh, I have a couple of clips
of comrades inside the play,
but maybe I'll do it after both of you go,
'cause I don't wanna-
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
- Oh, you can play it now.
- Not like the last time.
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
Okay, all, right.
I don't know if this works,
can people just hear me if I shout?
Okay, so one of the
things when I was trying
to think of something useful to say today
was that I just wanted,
really people to hear from folks inside,
who I organized with.
So, I'm just gonna play a couple of clips.
I asked them to share
a few words with you.
The first one is from
a dear comrade, Lawrence Jenkins,
he's incarcerated in Washington State.
Just a revolutionary,
organizer, farmer, artist.
And the second and Stevie Wilson,
who folks might be familiar with as well,
who's incarcerated in Pennsylvania.
So, I'll just share those.
- [Lawrence] I wanna
speak on the importance
of political education and solidarity
in our struggle to survive, get free,
and stay free.
But first, I would like to address
the shortcomings of
the prison abolition movement today.
There is a belief that future aid
and general (indistinct) respondents alone
will help us survive
genocide and escape torture,
when instead, these caring acts only help
us manage and cope with these conditions
while doing nothing to
liberate us from them.
This approach will only help prisoners
suffer peacefully and while assimilating
our movement into the power establishment,
it was control
of (indistinct) state
violence and depression.
The very thing that developed (indistinct)
as a tool to displace and dispose
an entire community.
This must be met with critical resistance
and revolutionary action.
It is on us abolitionists
for sincerely committed,
not just to thought in words,
but in action and practical application.
We are confronting material conditions
that must be done away with completely.
We are embracing visions, programs,
and processes that ensure
autonomy, independence,
collective self-determination
and sustainability.
These are things we've identified
as primary aims and objectives
to ensure our survival,
maintain our freedom,
and secure our destiny.
Now, we are committed to
do this until they free us.
Being that we were
having this conversation
in a higher (indistinct)
institution today,
I must emphasize importance
of political education, as
well as cultural studies
and why it's needed for prisoners.
Simply put, we lost the knowledge
of what we once knew.
We lost control of what we once want.
We lost the belief that we can do whatever
we put our mind to.
We need this reeducation
and re-empowerment
in order to further develop
a counterculture that can be shared
with the mass movement
fighting on our behalf,
and on behalf of our
loved ones in community
against mass imprisonment,
racism, and oppression.
We are all at different
stages of development
in our journey.
Each state has its own
laws, policy and practices.
Even prison has its own variation
of genocide, slavery, and
cruel, identified torture,
but that's leading us where we are at.
Coming with a sincere commitment
to helping us over...
To helping us come to a level
of consciousness and
ability that will help
us not only meet our basic needs,
but also help us achieve
our (indistinct) objectives
and secure our freedom.
And Grace Lee Boggs taught us
about revolutionary humanism, organization
means commitment, and that's what we need
from today, the abolitionists over.
- Is there a way to turn
up the volume at all?
Because the people on Zoom are having
a hard time hearing.
- Can I turn up the volume from here?
Can you do it? Okay.
- I don't know if that will help, but...
(audience chatters indistinctly)
And if not, then maybe we can post them
wherever we post that-
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
So, for those on Zoom, we will post
these audio files after the event.
- This is Stevie's (indistinct).
- [Stevie] I'm Stevie,
and I wanted to take
this opportunity to comment
on (indistinct) opportunity Garrett
and everyone else on
the panel for allowing
me to be a part of this event.
A few words about the
abolitionist movement.
(mumbles) so and I wanna begin
with a quotation from Edward Nathan
(mumbles) the common struggle.
It is that whatever you
kept alive (indistinct)
the struggle, you will always be
your own (indistinct) equal struggling
it's equal partners.
Therefore, and this is
one of the problems,
all of the (indistinct).
If you think of the prison segue
into (indistinct) of this, you can see
the great purpose of being in that work.
You were constituting them as superior
in the process of trying to right.
(indistinct) said by saying-
- [Call Operator] This is a call
from Pennsylvania State
Correctional Institution, Camp Hill.
This call is subject to
recording and monitoring.
- [Stevie] You can say (indistinct)
the abolitionist movement
has (mumbles indistinctly) of prisoners,
there to be a campaign,
just as a matter of fact.
It may always be
(indistinct) participation
of prisoners from a
to acknowledging of equal (indistinct).
And I find myself repeating this
quite often to people on the outside.
Investigation, they need to look
at the in prison population
and equal partners,
and they need to be
connected to people inside.
Because the only way they're going know
what's happening in here,
really what's happening in here
is that you are connected
to people inside.
You cannot depend upon on the state
to tell you how you're treating us.
You cannot depend up on
the state to tell you
what's going on in here.
So, it's important to be connected
to people inside, and
I've also said before
that if you are doing this work,
and you are not connected
to someone inside-
(speaker drowned out by
background noise) wrong.
So, I think, that's important for us
to be connected to one another.
And that we have to think about ways also
that we can (indistinct) an opportunity
to contribute for people inside
and how we can get...
How we can actually grow
the capacity people inside.
And one of the ways is collaboration.
I encourage everyone
to truly collaborate with people inside,
to (indistinct) the capacity
of the people inside.
Which is really important instead
of coming to the project
already formulated
and asking people to participate in it,
and asking you to actually create
these programs, create these projects
for the people inside, and not be like
the DOC, Department of Corrections,
where actually, they never
asked for our consent.
And they only asked for our cooperation,
actually kinda forced us to cooperate.
That's kinda, a lot of people out there
who are doing this work too.
And I mention consent,
'cause quite often, people outside
who are doing this work,
they make statements.
They (indistinct) campaign,
they take action on
behalf of people inside,
but they don't ask us
if that's what we want.
They don't ask our opinion.
They don't ask us for our consent-
- [Call Operator] This is a call
from Pennsylvania State
Correctional Institution, Camp Hill.
This call is subject to
recording and monitoring.
- [Stevie] To this problem,
and I'll just give you two examples
what was in Florida,
where there would be
issue around prison labor
and people who were complaining
about the (mumbles indistinctly)
that are up in the prison.
And there were 80 people
on the grounds crew
and they were complaining about it.
And it wasn't the prisoners complaining
about it, it was actually
the people outside.
And so, the prisoners decided
to get riding motors and eliminate
the crew and that's (mumbles
indistinctly) people
working in the seven...
Up to 78 people are (mumbles indistinctly)
on this day.
So, (indistinct) talking
to people outside first
thing (indistinct).
He talks of how (mumbles
indistinctly) Colorado
where there was a lot of bad feelings
with the people inside who were looking
at what they
were doing outside (indistinct) visit.
The state constitution, (mumbles) slavery
and the state constitution.
And people inside were afraid
they were gonna not be able to work
as well, but people
inside (mumbles) to work.
They have a reason why they wanna work
and they want to,
but they afraid, they want a good job.
And so, I think, it's important
that we look at these campaigns, look
at these ads, whatever we're doing.
Get connected to the
people (mumbles) inside
(mumbles) I mean, campaign.
That would be most
impacted by your actions.
See, that's so important,
but (mumbles indistinctly)
as far as the movement itself,
this movement (mumbles) of the people
(mumbles indistinctly) wants to be.
So, we need to actually
also create materials that are accessible
to the masses.
Something we struggle with inside,
a lot of work is being
done in A, academics,
and talking to academics, (indistinct)
and talking to the masses.
So, we used to advocate work that talks
to the people because we're not going
to work without the people.
So, I really stress that point,
and there are some people
who were willing to read that,
like they wanna be read.
And like Chibuki and Mary
(indistinct) Alberts.
Another person on the panel, Derecka,
(mumbles indistinctly) read.
So, and this stuff
working to keep it aside
and explain abolition to the people inside
because these are people to think about.
So, I just...
A couple things I want
people to think about,
about getting connected, thinking
about (indistinct),
'cause I want us to think
about collaboration and understanding
that we need to be connected and connected
and increase our branch of people
to be able to participate.
Potentially people
inside and their families
and to think about how we can do that.
Uh-huh, thank you.
- So, I'll do a quick side
that Stevie's was harder to hear.
This is speaker phone into my computer.
Just to summarize a couple
of the key points that Stevie was making.
One of them is to get connected
to people inside and engage
in true collaboration with them.
So, he was talking a little bit
about these sort of programs
that are pre for emulate outside
and then come in to sort of superimpose
a vision onto folks inside and
how that sort of correlates
to the DOC's relationship and sort of led
that to talk about consent.
and how some of these campaigns
that people formulate outside.
And he gives examples from Florida,
and also, Colorado with
trying to eradicate
the sort of clause of the 13th Amendment.
That people inside were
actually quite concerned
about what eliminating
that clause might do
for their jobs that they
rely on for sustenance
for themselves and their families.
So, to collaborate and also think
about consent from people inside
when you're doing these
sort of organizing.
And then lastly, about accessibility.
I think, one thing that
Stevie always talks
about is how the literature being written
about movements and incarceration
from within the academy
is just simply inaccessible.
So, a lot of the work that we do together
is a translation of books into zines.
And then, he was shouting
out Derecka's work
as an example of writing the way
that you wanna be read.
- [Robin] Mm-hmm.
- So, thanks for listening.
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
(audience applauds)
- Hi, oh, okay.
There's no strings.
I thought it was like strings.
(Elizabeth chuckles)
It just comes up.
Hi, and it doesn't.
Okay, here we go.
Hi, everyone.
(Elizabeth chuckles)
How are y'all doing?
- [Female] Okay.
- Good.
- Okay, never mind.
(audience laughs)
Yes, thank...
Garrett, one thing I really appreciate
about you, and I first
experienced this at MUMI.
It was the first conference
that I had gone to where in the planning
there was a level of intentionality
to make sure that people who
were currently incarcerated
are part of the conversation.
And so, I'm just so grateful
that you did that just now,
that we were able to
hear from two comrades
who are inside.
So, thank you so much
for always making sure
that when we talk about this work,
we also are actively doing that
and it means so much to me,
and it's deeply inspirational.
So, thank you.
I also, who was the...
What was the name of the
first person who spoke?
- Lawrence.
- Lawrence, it's so interesting.
Last night, I had a conversation
with a group of students
at the Graduate Club,
who are in the grand
strategic pro grand strategy.
(audience laughs)
Grand strategy?
Grand strategy.
- [Garrett] Yeah.
- Yes, and I heard some feedback,
so y'all gonna have to gimme
the tea later about that program.
(audience laughs)
I heard some things,
but not everything,
but one of the students
asked me a question.
I can't remember it right now.
It was sort of like, what is my concern
about what's one of my fears.
And I shared that I was nervous
about the deep pessimistic turn
to mutual aid in the...
In recent years.
Because mutual aid is
obviously very important
and I think, it helps us save lives
and I also shared that.
I think that the homic...
The spike in homicides that we've seen
in the last couple of years
were probably even higher,
but for the very important interventions
that people were able to provide
and pay rent, provide shelter.
Do makeshift daycares to
take care of each other.
But I'm also nervous
about the pessimistic turn
to mutual aid, which is,
this is the only thing
that we can do, and I
have some control over it.
And we're never gonna win.
The state is just going
to find some other way to shift.
And we have to figure out
how to do that terrain.
So, I'm gonna figure out how just
to pay individual's bills.
I'm gonna figure out how just to make sure
that people can eat,
because as Lawrence said,
that then removes our
impulse to fight against
the repression of the state,
which is going to continue.
And so, I just am so grateful
that he said that just directly
and straightforwardly,
and it's a deep critique
that I also share of the movement
that we have now.
I just didn't anticipate that,
it's not something I...
That historically I know
there have been pessimistic
moves towards flight
and going inward, but that
was one concrete thing.
That's when he said it, I said, okay,
I know other people are
thinking about this too.
All right, so what were
the questions abolition something-
- [Garrett] So, yeah, your journey.
Your journey-
- Journey, yeah!
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
Yeah, yeah, it was...
Yeah, so that's complicated.
Okay, I did write a book
about this thing, but...
(audience laughs)
The book isn't like,
I was a reformer and
now I'm an abolitionist.
So, that is not that,
that is not the book at all.
I hope that that's not what I...
Anyone in this room expects,
'cause that's not what the book is,
because no one's born a reformer.
No one came out being like,
I'm gonna reform the
police, where's my bottle?
(audience laughs)
Like no one.
That's not true for anyone.
What often happens is that we're born
when unexamined ideas about the world
and then we're socialized
in the institution
that we belong to, to
develop ideas about them.
Me, I grew up watching Cops, right?
I still fight with my mom
because she watch Law and Order,
SVU specifically, right?
Okay, all right, so-
- [Robin] I'm watching that, so yeah.
- SD, I know, I know, no
shade to Lisa Garrett.
(Robin laughs)
Yes, it's very...
We learn these.
I actually didn't even remember that,
so it was no shade to Lisa.
Yeah, I'll tell her I'm sorry.
(Robin and audience laugh)
Yeah, so we're socialized, right?
And so, I watch people in
my community become cops
because they wanted to be better
than the racist cop that they encountered.
And I knew my mom had a couple
of friends who were cops.
And I also knew that we ran from cops
and cops chased us.
So, I knew that when
someone's home was being,
getting invaded because
a social worker deemed
them to be unfit parents,
cops were right there
to remove children from home.
So, I was deeply afraid of them.
So, there's all these
different touchpoints
with policing and with prisons.
And so one actually...
(computer beeps)
Oh, one story I talk about in the book
is this campaign that I worked on
to close a jail in St. Louis called,
The Work House.
And when I was a kid, I
had known so many people
to go in and out of The Work House
that I thought it was a
place where you got a job.
(Robin chuckles)
- [Robin] Wow.
- I was like, it's called
The Work House.
- [Robin] Okay.
- I didn't know that The
Workhouse historically
are jails where people
went, who were enslaved
and run away, or are poor
and had to pay a debt
in order to secure their release.
And so, it took years before
I understood that, oh, this is a jail
and people don't come back for days,
or weeks, or months.
But again, just my experiences
with police, and prisons, and prosecutors,
it didn't automatically
give me an analysis
of whether they were worthy of redemption,
or could be reformed, or
needed to abolish, right?
That came through political struggle.
And it was so funny
listening to Garrett talk
about Black Study, Black Struggle,
and Robin saying something
about the study groups.
And you were like, "What, what's that?"
Well, I remember when I first met Robin,
he was on the panel at Harvard
and he was talking about
political education,
political education, political education.
And I raised my hand and I was like,
"Well, what do I need to read
for my political education?"
And he was like, "Well,
I can't tell you that.
It's really going to
come down to the people
who you organize with."
'Cause you have to read the
political materials to debate
and inform the campaign,
or fight that you're struggling around.
And I thought that was BS.
(audience laughs)
I wanted Robin to give
me like, eight books.
I wanted a political education starter kit
and he was not about that life.
I was very frustrated about it.
(Robin laughs)
And then, I went to South
Africa and I watched,
I watched that happen.
I watched students read
and debate different
political texts, and how...
And they used that to inform the demands
that they needed in order to fight
for the freedoms that they wanted.
So, I was there.
I was watching students say,
"Our movement is about free education
because we think that education
is a tool of empowerment,"
similar to what Lawrence
just said on the call.
And we believe that it
will help facilitate
our fight for the land here.
And so, they were making these
broader connections between
their educational struggles,
and these broader decolonial demands
that to help transform the
world that they belong to.
And I said this the other day,
I was like, "Well, I was
there watching them read
and debate, sometimes
physically fight over
their ideas, 'cause it...
They knew that there was so much at stake.
And I remember coming back to
the west and thinking about
our student demands that weren't informed
about political education.
And I was like, they're
trying to get the land.
we're trying to get a diversity office.
(audience laughs)
Like it was not the same.
This is very, very different.
(audience laughs)
Very, very, very different,
but that showed me how important
a political education man, how important,
how important it was to be a part
of a political home and
a political organization.
To help spur your own
individual development,
but to also do that with other people
and you guys are growing and figuring out
how to waste these
fights for the long term.
And it doesn't directly answer
my journey to become an abolitionist,
'cause it wasn't linear, right?
It happened, a lot of
people become politicized
in social movements.
You sort of hear people talking
about different ideas, abolished borders,
or more diversity.
And you can't quite make sense of them.
You know that there is a broader history
of people who fight for racial,
and freedom, and justice.
But until we start understanding
the role of political education,
we don't understand that history, right,
of people who are on the good side,
it's very different from
something like tradition.
- [Robin] Mm-hmm.
- Where people fight
for different things according
to a set of belief that they think
will help propel them
towards something greater.
And I was being politicized around
these different traditions.
Nile is gonna kill me, but I was telling
his story literally the other day too,
about at his parents house.
There's a picture on a wall
and it's like Barack
Obama and Tupac Shakur,
and Harriet Tubman, and Fannie Lou Hamer,
and all these amazing
black figures in history.
Like riding on horses to freedom, right?
And I remember years ago I would've seen
a picture like that and been like,
"Oh, this is so amazing.
Look at our history, right?"
And then, you develop some
political analysis, right?
Especially radical leftist
political analysis.
And you realize that these are all very,
very different people that we group
in together and say,
"Look at our history."
All right, Kamala Harris
and Fannie Lou Hamer,
very, very different.
(audience laughs)
Very, very, very different, you know?
Would not recommend one,
they're very, very, very different, right?
And so, but we would just loop them in,
when we group them
together as black people
and black women who are trying to fight
for that seat at the table.
We miss what makes them possible.
And so, I was being pushed around,
what are these different institutions?
Like policing, like
prisons, like capitalism,
like all these things I
had taken for granted,
even though I had different
touchpoints with them.
'Cause I had been student organizer since
I was about 14, trying to make sense
of them alone.
And then, once I realized, "Okay,
I have to go through this
and understand this with other people."
That's why I started developing
more radical politics.
Simply because I was surrounded by people
who were more curious than I was,
who were more courageous than I was,
who were more radical than I was.
And who were honestly patient,
who weren't trying to convert me
to do something, to
believe something, right?
Who were actually trying to invite me
to understand a set of radical politics
that then, we can force together.
So, that's why I really hope
the spirit of the book is,
is actually less about this is where I was
and now, this is where I am.
But actually, all of these touchpoints
for different people
I encounter, other
organizers, other movements,
other ideas that help me understand
that the invitation to
understand radical politics
is much, much, much more
than we identify as an
individual abolitionist.
Which is why the title is
plural and not singular.
- [Robin] Right.
- 'Cause it's not just
about my individual story,
but this generation who really
hasn't been in conversation with people
in the other parts of the world,
and people across time, and
figured out how to get free.
- [Robin] Right, mm.
(audience applauds)
- That is so true.
And you know, you really,
if you don't have the book, shame on you.
(Derecka and audience chuckle)
You really need to get it
because in some ways it is both exactly
what Derecka said in
terms of movement history,
but it also is about the way concepts
like abolition change over time
in struggle.
- Mm-hmm.
- It doesn't change because
a think tank is better
than another think tank,
it's the movements themselves
produce certain kinds of (mumbles).
So, let me... Let me go,
I took all these notes.
I love the image, this
image of the picture.
See, my generation.
- Yes.
- The pictures that you had on the wall
were like kings of Africa,
a Budweiser, right?
(Derecka and audience laugh)
And you talk about being traumatized,
like kings of Africa,
that was like our heroes.
It wasn't like kings
of Africa anti-imperialist kings.
- No, Mansa Musa, like that kind of-
- Right, exactly.
- That kind of energy.
- And also, I just
wanna remind people that
that piece, Black Study Black Struggle
is a forum, it's not juts my essay.
And in the forum is a really
brilliant contribution
by Derecka Purnell.
So, you need to read the whole forum,
even the people who talk
really bad about me.
(group chuckles)
But it's really worth checking out.
And it was a really important
kind of intervention.
I really have, before I
sort of answer the question,
I just have to acknowledge
how important it is to be
with these three people.
Specifically because I'm the elder,
I know that, but I'm also the student
of all three.
And if you want, if you have to...
I don't wanna give lists,
but if you have to read three books
that has to do with the struggle
to try to end the carceral state
in state violence,
you read Garrett, Liz and Derecka's book.
Those, and of course, both of Liz's books.
These are really essential texts,
and there's nothing like having Liz Hinton
as my student, because she was also
my research assistant, among other things.
But I take a lot of notes.
I learned so much from her.
I learned so much from Garrett.
When Garrett was working
on the Malcolm X project,
and I was like...
And of course, Derecka.
So, I'm a student of these three people,
and I'm a student of many, many people.
When I think about my own journey,
I think about the folks I learned
from over the years.
I'm talking early years, but later years.
I'm a student of Eliza Kelly.
I'm a student of Sherry Randolph,
who's over there.
I mean, Sherry was a student of mine,
but I was really a student of hers.
Michael Denning remembers those days
when a handful of us
would get on the train
to come to New Haven,
to participate with
all the faculty at Yale
to support the Union.
What was it four people?
It was like you and
Hazel, David Montgomery.
(audience laughs)
So, it's like I learned
from Michael over the years.
So, I'm very fortunate.
I'm just a student.
So, having said that, I'm not gonna answer
the question on what is abolition,
because I think, both the brilliant answer
that Garrett gave and everything
that Derecka said, especially in her book;
answers that question for me.
But I'll say some things about my journey,
'cause it helps to understand
how I came to understand abolition.
And so, first of all, I
have to begin by saying,
back in the 1980s,
no one called themselves an abolitionist.
To say that you're for abolition
was a very specific thing.
It was like you're for abolishing prisons
and abolishing the police.
And so, it wasn't an identity.
So, I come...
So, at 18 years old,
I'm a communist, okay?
And very proud of it.
- [Audience Member] Woo hoo.
(Derecka chuckles)
And so, when you're a
communist and you're 18,
you already have a view of the world,
what it could be.
And that view is things
that we think of as anti,
we call it anti capitalist now.
We didn't say anti-capitalist,
we just assumed, (laughs)
it was anti capitalist.
- [Derecka] Yeah.
- The destruction of capitalism itself.
Seizing... Well of course, we had
a state centered, state oriented idea.
So, you seize the state,
but the most important things
that things like a
transformed environment,
a fair wage, housing, transportation,
ultimately the elimination of commodities,
these are the things that we dreamed of.
What's interesting about being a communist
in the 19, basically,
1980, really, to be honest.
80, 81, is that we didn't always think
of the prison, at least not my circles,
as the thing that needs to be eliminated.
What we did do though,
is that we had a sense of
what a political prisoner was.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- And this goes back to the title
of Garrett's book on Martin Sostre.
We didn't realize that they're
all political prisoners.
Of course, that idea is emerging.
In 1976, you have a... You
have development of documents
that are arguing for
the abolition of prison.
So, I grew up in the generation
that said free Jeronimo Ji Jaga Pratt,
free Sandiago (indistinct).
Assata Shakur broke out,
but there was a free Assata
Shakur at some point.
So, '70s into the 1980s,
there was a whole question
about political prisoners
as a separate category.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- Now, so here's my development.
Number one, in 1988, I'm a
brand new PhD just finished.
I meet Ruth Wilson Gilmore,
who becomes a lifelong friend.
She was on her way to graduate school.
She actually, she's a
Yale alum in theater,
you know that, right?
Do you know that?
Oh, you know that.
(audience chuckles)
But, so she was on her
way to go to Rutgers,
to do a PhD in geography.
And she had some ideas that blew my mind,
and we weren't talking about abolition,
but she was talking about the
relationship between space,
prison construction, and all the violence
that happens to the land, to
the environment, to workers,
and to human beings put in cages.
And she's trying to
figure that out spatially.
And so, we had those early conversations
are like, wow, that's amazing.
So, of course, we
maintain lifelong friends.
I take my second job, which is a job
at the University of Michigan.
And so, we have a Michigan connection,
Liz Garrett, me.
And they know, so I was there 1991
to about 1994.
Eliza was a little baby.
And so, well, I'm there and
I end up doing two things
that are significant.
One, I teach at a place
called Boysville, 1992.
Boysville is a place where they
detain kids, male children.
This is the carceral state,
this is the juvenile detention center.
And I go in there and I'm
teaching, and all I see are poets.
That's all I see, a
whole room full of poets,
beautiful children,
they're all black and
the couple Latin X kids.
But black kids, or poets, and I'm like,
and you're in here.
And they made me poetry.
I still have that poetry.
They made laminated poems, right?
And then, while I'm
there, Michigan, teaching
at the University of Michigan,
I had an opportunity
to go to Jackson State
and meet some of the older brothers there.
And what do I find?
Poets, everywhere you turn, poets,
and they're intellectuals,
and they're writers,
and they're scholars.
And they want to get out.
There's no reason for them
to be behind barbwire,
or to have to spend 90 minutes a day,
or two hours a day in a yard.
And we're in the yard
talking to them, right?
And so, my mind's sort of spinning,
like this is not even...
So, the question of political prisoners
sort of cease to be as prominent
because you begin to realize
that there's a politics of imprisonment.
When you find, when you
hear people's stories,
sometimes they might make
a mistake, or whatever,
and they end up in jail.
A lot of times it's just petty stuff,
and yet, there are people I know
who are in my class at the
University of Michigan,
who do petty stuff that's way worse.
And they're not in prison, you know?
They go home in their BMWs,
and they're paying
out-of-state tuition, whatever.
So, then it's that.
And then, all this is swirling,
and then in 1994, Angela Davis
is participating in this conference
called Race Matters.
And I'm also one of the speakers.
I'm really young, not so young anymore,
but so I'm there, Michael R. Dyson,
a bunch of people, Angela
Davis gives this speech
and the room is packed.
This is at Princeton.
This is in celebration of
Cornell Westbook, Race Matters,
Race Matters Conference.
And in this speech, she says,
she basically gives a speech
that becomes prisons, or prisons obsolete.
- [Garrett] Mm-hmm.
- And she says in this packed room,
and they're there because
she's a celebrity.
They're there, not 'cause they read any
of her stuff.
It's like packed.
People just on the rafters at Princeton.
And she says, "It is
time to abolish prisons."
And you could...
You could hear a pin drop.
(male chuckles)
Those people are like, "What?"
And I'm there watching the whole thing
and people lie to you.
Say people say like I was
at the March of Washington, they're lying.
(group laughs)
You know, it's the same thing.
They'll say, "Oh no, I was with her."
No, they weren't.
(group chuckles)
Nobody was with her.
(group laughs)
Nobody was with her on that.
(Derecka claps)
And these are young people.
And the first thing they did hand shot up.
What about the rapists?
These are black people,
young black students
at Princeton, the creme de la creme.
I'm sorry, Yales, the crem de la crem.
(audience laughs)
That's secondary.
So, what I'm saying is that
that was mind blowing because I was there.
When I say, when I was there,
I was there politically.
I'd arrived to completely
agree with her on this.
And that was 1994.
So, in some ways I have to give credit,
not to my own thinking independently.
It's not even...
And I wouldn't even say
that it's entirely activism.
So, that's a part of it.
Part of it is that I was fortunate
to be surrounded by
thinkers and intellectuals
who thought through these things.
And showed a mirror to what the prisons
really do to people.
Between Ruthie, Angela,
these kids at Boysville,
the folks at Jackson State.
And then, then of course,
you start to read.
And finally, the last
thing is just dealing
with police violence.
So, Jill Nelson published
this book called, "Police Brutality,"
came out in 1999.
And that book is as relevant today
as it is, as it was then.
This is right.
In fact, it was on the eve of...
Was it on eve of, or no,
it was after Amadou
Diallo, around that time.
And so, the point is,
is that that book, in that book,
I kind of made the case at the very end
of my essay, which is kind of a history
of police violence, was that we need
to abolish the police.
That's 1999, I'm not the first one
to say that, obviously.
But my point is that that was a huge move
and it wasn't, again, it wasn't
a move from reform to
a revolutionary stance,
'cause I always...
I mean, I was a communist.
I believed in socialism and still do,
but the point is,
is that it's amazing how
the carceral structures
are often taken for granted.
We talk about the role
in reproduction of
capital, but not always...
but there was a belief that somehow
they could be transformed or reformed,
because there's some people who need that.
That we need police, that we need prisons.
So, the leap is huge.
And that's why the last thing
I'll just say about this,
and that's why we have to...
We have to remember and Derecka makes
this point in her book,
that as much as we talk about
the 13th Amendment and the 14th Amendment,
but the 13th amendment, the clause
that says essentially, you could still
have slavery as long as
someone commits a crime.
Nobody was questioning
that in 1865, or 66,
because in fact, Du Bois,
in his grand black reconstruction
was very proud of the fact
that reconstruction moved
from the prison camp
to the penitentiary.
That the penitentiary
was the modern iteration,
the safer, more humane sort of solution
to deal with prisoners.
So, we've made a huge leap from that,
but it's not we're not going back
to an older abolition,
this is a new abolition.
And that was a product
of these kinds of struggles.
So, that's sort of my
journey, but I just...
I've stopped there and just simply say,
we have to always pay attention
to the institutions that
have become so normative.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- And that's not just the prison,
it's the family.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- There's all kinds of things
that we think about that.
We think it was normative that
those things are untouchable,
we just have to fix them.
So, we have to think
really hard about that.
So, to be an abolitionist
is to change everything
as Ruthie would say.
- [Derecka] Yes.
- And it's to live life in rehearsal,
which is also Ruthie's term.
So, I'll stop there.
(group applauds)
- Thank you all for sharing
and for those comments.
It's a reminder, I think,
as Garrett said that abolition itself
isn't linear, that it's
constantly evolving
and that it grows out of ideas,
and discussion, and struggle.
So, three of us up here
are historians and I would be remiss
if I didn't invite us
to talk about history.
And so, Robin and Garrett,
I'd like you to share some
of your expertise on the history of,
and struggles for racial justice.
And Robin, we just read
portions of "Hammer
and Hoe" in my African
American history survey.
So, the Alabama Sharecroppers' Union
has been on my mind a lot lately.
And I'm wondering if you could
just help us think through some lessons
that we can learn about how to organize
and sustain radical social movement
from the history of communist organizing
in the '30s and '40s.
As well as drawing from other aspects
of your work, maybe
cultural forms like jazz,
and hip hop.
And Garrett, and those who know,
don't say you introduce
a concept called the
dialectics of discipline
as a way to consider the
kind of simultaneous rise
of collective black resistance,
and escalating state repression.
Like increased reliance on solidarity.
Solitary confinement, and
maximum security prisons
as a reaction to protest and mobilization
among incarcerated people.
And you, in many ways,
all of your work helps
us see how the carceral
state and the movement
to abolish it, really rose together.
So, I guess, it's a similar question
that I'm asking of Robin,
and that is what can
abolitionists today learn
from the struggle of
incarcerated Muslim activists
in the '50s and '60s?
And where do we see the dialectics
of discipline in prisons today?
- Well, Garrett can go first.
(audience chatters and chuckles)
- Well chronologically.
(chuckles)
(panelists chatter indistinctly)
- Oh.
(Elizabeth laughs)
No, you need to be in
the history question too, no.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I have-
- No.
- Well, I have a third-
- I figured there was
another question. (laughs)
- I'll pose that now.
I'll pose it now.
So, the question that I had for Derecka,
I think, everybody can comment
on these questions,
but since you're the lawyer among us,
she's the only one on stage with a JD.
- Barely, Jesus.
- I would really love for you
to reflect on the relationship
between abolition and the law.
And as you know well,
the law has really served
to kind of facilitate
and legitimate state violence
against marginalized groups.
But it also has functioned at times
as an instrument of
protection and justice.
So, slavery is abolished, we get Jim Crow.
Jim Crow's abolished, we
get mass criminalization.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I'm wondering what
limits and possibilities
the law might offer for abolition.
- Mm-hmm, right.
- The law and the state,
'cause that also came up.
- Yeah.
- I mean, do you want me
to go first, 'cause...
- [Elizabeth] Anybody-
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
- Cause I'll be actually, I'm not gonna...
I'll be very brief.
- [Elizabeth] Okay.
- I can't answer the second question,
which is kind of cultural forms,
but I will talk about specifically
the Communist Party and
the Sharecroppers' Union,
because I think if there's a lesson there,
I mean, we have to remember
that these movements were crushed.
I mean, crushed to the point
where there was almost no memory.
And so, we have to be prepared
in terms of the longevity movements
to recognize that that
there's a dialectic,
there's ebbs and flows.
And we wouldn't have had, I mean,
for the Sharecroppers' Union
and for the labor organizing in the 1930s,
I mean the truth of the matter
is that it took a lot of
courage, mobilization,
a sense of crisis,
but it also took space
that the state created.
And we don't always talk about this,
but as problematic as the new deal was
and as racist as it was, certain things
were products of worker struggles.
And this goes back to the question
that you posed about mutual aid,
versus the struggle of state.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- That they're not necessarily
mutually exclusive.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- That the struggle to create
a National Labor Relations Board,
which of course, doesn't
affect Sharecroppers',
'cause they're not even covered, right?
But that did create space
for unionizing and for pushing back
against companies that create,
basically company unions to undermine
the organizing efforts.
In terms of the Sharecroppers',
they may not have had
the National Labor
Relations Board behind them,
but they had a couple things behind them.
The belief that with all
this dynamic organizing going on,
that they also need to
be out there organizing.
Even if it meant engaging
in shootouts with police.
And then secondly, the most amazing thing,
this has to do with internationalism.
The most successful movements
in the 20th century are those
that actually either
have connections beyond borders.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- Or believe they have connections.
You don't have to have, actually
have real connections,
but what's beautiful about
the Communist Party in Alabama
is that they're like, we are an extension
of the Soviet power.
And we know, and they said this,
I mean, some people I interviewed said,
"We knew that when we
went on strike in 1935,
if anything were to happen to us,
that Stalin would send troops.
He would send ships across the Atlantic
into mobile and troops would come
into Alabama and protect us.
That's solidarity.
Now, that didn't happen,
but the belief in it,
the belief that somehow, you're part
of something larger and
that the working class
is not a national class.
It's an international class.
And this was...
This has always been the Achilles heel
of American working class struggles,
both as nationalism
and nationalism translates into what?
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- White nationalism.
- It is black workers, workers of color
have been always at the
forefront of saying,
we see ourselves as a class.
It's the white workers that make
the mistake of seeing
themselves as a race.
And when they see themselves as a race,
then they end up joining the wrong side.
And this was the message
that the boys taught us.
And this is the message of the 1930s,
because what happened was once you had
the wind of the federal
government behind your back,
or belief in it,
all the white folks,
who started to realize
that wait a second,
we don't have any other
option but to organize.
And they actually were able to win over
a segment of white working class.
And I think, for us in the 21st century,
this is important, and I'm not making
a case against "identity politics",
'cause my belief in
identity politics goes back
to Barbara Smith.
And combine, they have a
different understanding of it.
But I do think it's important not
to get caught up in the silos,
and to build power, means to basically,
you don't have to give up identity,
but you do to build power across
the lines of these silos.
And sometimes, building power
means to mobilize people,
who at first, are against you.
It means mobilizing people
who may share your same interests-
- Mm-hmm.
- Politically, but they don't know better.
What's the point of political education?
- Right.
- Right?
It's a political to basically get people
to agree with you and get them in the room
and say, "Yeah, Walter Rodney, you know?"
(group chuckles)
Or is it to try to build people
who don't really know?
Because the thing is,
it's not as if the state
is picking and choosing who they're trying
to bring into their realm, right?
So, we have to think in those terms,
and those are the lessons
to me of the 1930s.
- [Garrett] Where are we
going, chronologically?
- [Elizabeth] Yeah-
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
- [Garrett] Okay, so
I'm all over the place.
I think, I'm gonna interpret
the question as sort of a broader,
like what can we learn from the struggles
of imprisoned people?
'Cause I think that I'm thinking
of the new project too, and just what
you all are saying.
And I mean, for me, not even historically,
just in this moment,
like what thinking about
the struggles of imprisoned
people has allowed
me to do is see everything
else differently.
So, I see the university differently
because I understand its relationship
to policing and prisons.
And that's been useful for me.
I mean, when we think about
these sort of campaigns
to have cops off campus, right?
Yale can't exist without
police in prisons.
It's not just about eradicating police
from the campus, right?
The only way that Yale can operate
through dispossession,
through incarceration,
through imprisonment, through land seizure
is through police and prisons.
So, when you read George Jackson talking
about fascism-
- [Derecka] Yeah, yeah, yes.
- Reform, right?
It's like, people don't think
we're living in a fascist police state,
but it's because you don't feel
the fascist police state the way
that Lawrence feels it.
- [Robin] Mm-hmm.
- The way that Stevie feels it.
- [Robin] Right.
- They would think it's ridiculous
to say we are not living in
a fascist police state.
Stevie can't receive his writings.
He writes things that are published
in the so-called free world
that he can then not receive back.
That's fascism.
- [Robin] Fascism.
- But it's not fascism
if we don't feel it, right?
That's what we think.
I talk about collective dreaming.
This project that I'm writing
that Robin and Derecka
were so gracious to read.
I try to share my
writings on Martin Sostre,
who's this revolutionary anarchist,
political prisoner with people inside.
They can't read it.
So, there's all this kind of like, talk
about censorship and anti CRT,
and book bannings.
It's happening every day, I promise you.
If you are a politicized prisoner,
everything you do is mediated through
the state, through fascism.
So, I think what's valuable about not
just studying these struggles,
but being in solidarity
with and in community
with people is you're able to understand
the way that all these unseen forces
of criminalization and incarceration
are shaping this.
In a way that you wouldn't
understand otherwise.
I don't know if I answered
your question at all.
- [Robin] Yeah.
(audience chuckles)
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
It's a great answer.
- Okay.
- No, it's important.
It's important, I'm just thinking
about so much about where to even...
Where to even start, so
abolition and the law.
(sighs) The law is kind of trash.
I don't know.
(audience laughs)
I don't know, I'm trying to figure out
where's the best way to even start.
Is anyone in here in law school,
or want to go to law school,
or walk passed a law school?
(group laughs)
- [Elizabeth] There are some,
but they're not the reason they're here.
- Some, okay, yeah.
(Elizabeth laughs)
- Oh, no, it's so interesting.
(sighs) Where do you start this?
So, are you asking if they're compatible,
are they relation to each other?
- [Elizabeth] I'm just
wondering how you see,
I mean, 'cause you're a law...
You're an abolition, I mean, and you have
a law degree, you are a lawyer.
- I do have a law degree.
- [Elizabeth] So, what are-
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
How can the law be a
tool, or is it just trash?
I mean, maybe it's just trash and it's-
- Well, yeah, well some trash is useful.
That's why we go-
(group laughs)
Let me get this out,
or I wish I hadn't thrifted that shirt.
(group laughs)
So, it's complicated.
Yes, so what can I say?
I think that, yes, I've...
Sometimes we talk about politicization
as like an event that
happens is in our lives,
and then we're like,
"Whoa," but no, people
are constantly experiencing
different levels
of being politicized
when we're introducing different politics.
And so, I was politicized in abolition,
mostly in law school after
I already entered, right?
So, I talk about in the book
that Michael Brown was
killed about five minutes
from my house, about three weeks before
I started law school.
And so, I drove from
St. Louis to Cambridge,
trying to figure out how to wrap
my head around the movement
that was happening outside.
And then, you go to class,
and then, you have professors
who don't talk about it.
- [Robin] Mm.
- And then, you spend a year
in Dean of Students offices crying
so they can send an email
to acknowledge how violent
and painful this is.
To try to study for exams while
their are dead bodies going
viral on social media.
So, that that was like, what is going on?
Why am I learning about this
at this particular moment?
I think, what was interesting
when I told you all when I came back,
and I asked the students
I was organizing with.
There were a lot of us,
there were maybe like 100 students,
who were actively engaged on a daily basis
of trying to figure out how to connect
what we were learning to
what was happening outside.
And I said, "Hey, y'all, I think that
we should probably do political education,
'cause I don't think a diversity office
is gonna help change this.
I don't think that hiring
a critical race theorist
is gonna actually fundamentally shake up
the things that we're fighting for.
I think that we should read and study,
and think critically about
what we're trying to accomplish,
especially since we're
gonna be future lawyers.
And after lots of tense debates,
our movement split.
At least half of us left,
or half of that group left.
And they were like, I
just wanna sit around
and read, and affirm each
other about how right you are.
Y'all not trying to actually
win, or change Harvard.
So, we're gonna leave,
and the rest of us entered
us into a student occupation
for the next year and a half.
So, much so I graduated five years ago
and people still who go to HOS call
the space we occupy, Belinda Hall.
That is what we mean
when we claim that space,
which I think, is somewhat noteworthy.
But what was so beautiful
about Belinda Hall and us going through
our political education process,
it became the only space on campus
where anyone could teach, or take a class.
It didn't matter if you were
a dining services worker.
It didn't matter if you were a janitor,
it didn't matter if you were
a clinical faculty, you could teach,
or take a class, right?
It's where organizers from Boston
will come in and do, and train us
on organizing techniques, right?
It was a place where anyone could come
and eat is where we, said
we don't want police here.
I mean, police were
showing up to our visuals,
like to Boston, the black
Lawsuit Association,
when we would have candles
and people were crying.
It would be police.
And when you said that places at Yale
don't exist without the police,
it's sort of a concrete thing.
And so, to me, it's not always like,
"What about the murderers,
and what about the rapists?"
That's not why police primarily exist.
- [Robin] Right.
- They exist to manage
inequality and protect borders,
like internal borders,
external borders, right?
So, there are people who struggle
with that question so much, Elizabeth,
about how do I grapple with
these new sets of understanding
that I have about the
world and my role in it.
And then, reconcile that
with becoming a lawyer.
And there are people who gave up
their firm jobs.
People gave up $200,000 a year
to pay back their student debt
and became public defenders,
or intend to public service work.
There are some people who
said, I can't be a lawyer.
I can't reconcile this.
And they're a label
organizer still right now.
And so, people grapple with
it in a lot of different ways.
I told, I mean, Robin
knows this, every year
I have a crisis.
I'm like, should I be in a PhD program?
So, people were struggling with like,
can I actually be a lawyer?
And I think, the reason why I chose
to study for that horrible thing called
the bar exam, and then become a lawyer,
is because I knew that there were people
in St. Louis who were figuring out
how to put pressure on the
Ferguson Police Department.
Through this with the Department
of Justice called a consent decree,
and being a lawyer was one way
that I could help them.
And I already took out the debt.
I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna have to pay
back over $100,000 anyway,
might as well try it out a little bit.
And so, that's sort of what happened,
and I was...
I felt very lucky and very fortunate
to be able to do that.
And so, can you a tool?
Absolutely, I mean, if you're a lawyer,
you can get people outta jail,
or you can help people litigate.
You can do what I do,
which is those things,
but also, help think about policy
in a particular way to put it.
Your help gets bills drafted, right?
So, I think that's important.
I think that people in
our community do those things as well,
who are not lawyers.
There's people who do
participatory defense.
There are people who represent themselves
and get people outta jail.
I mean, the law's intentionally written
in a particular language, so that people
who take out hundreds of thousands
of student loan debt can articulate that
and then, make good on it.
So, it's really good job security, right?
But I'm always inspired
when I watch community based organizations
do court watching.
They're not, those people are not lawyers
and what do they do?
Every Monday in Kansas City we have 10
and two, go and watch eviction court.
And because of their presence,
because of their organizing,
they put pressure on the judge
to delay, or stop evictions.
You don't need a law
degree to do that, right?
So, I didn't know that before
I went to law school, but
the more that I lawyer,
the more that I organize,
the more that I write,
the more that I am in the social movement,
I learn how people decide to use the law.
But more importantly, how
to use their presence,
and their organizing as
tactics to manipulate the law
as a non-reformist reform.
Something that doesn't give
it more power and more legitimacy,
but actually, it's trying
to decrease the violence,
or at least, mitigate what
it's doing in the world.
So, I think, that's important,
and it's the answer I'm excited to give,
which is different than a question
I'm usually asked,
which is can I be an
abolitionist and a lawyer?
- [Robin] Mm-hmm.
- All right, that's the question
I feel like I'm asked the most at schools.
Say, "Can I do these things?"
I was like, "Well, I don't know."
I think, again, more important
than you identifying as
an abolitionist lawyer
is that you try to be
a part of a political
organization, and lawyer,
and try to figure out if you can use
your skills towards that broader movement.
And what's so fascinating,
the work that I do in that capacity
is not my lawyering work,
and I don't get paid for it, right?
I don't get paid to be on phone calls
for 15 hours a week,
thinking about student debt cancellation
with Dream Defenders.
That's not, I didn't go
to Harvard Law School
in order to do that, but that's something
that's something important to me,
'cause I know that once we figure out
how to make sure that we can cancel
and abolish all kinds of debts.
Fight for universal healthcare,
fight for free education,
it increases agency for people
to live the kind of lives
that they wanna live and we deserve it.
And so, yeah, I...
I mean, yeah, I think
everyone on this panel
will know that the way that so many
of our hopes and dreams,
especially given the
professionalization push
in the '80s and '90s.
If you wanna go do good in the world
to channel that through a career,
through a specific career,
it's like, "Yeah, I go do this thing."
And the right's not doing that.
- [Robin] Right.
- The right's not doing that.
- I know you said earlier,
what did you just say?
It reminded me of this,
that essentially the doors
of white supremacy are always open.
- Right.
(audience chuckles)
- That any moment, it's kind of like...
I'm serious-
- We were talking about it.
- At any moment, if you wanna go...
Oh, yeah we were talking about it, though
with the white workers.
At any moment, if you want to join
a white supremacist organization, you can.
You can go do this.
It's not, I mean, you obviously become
a cop or into the military,
into any one of these other positions,
but they are building,
that's grass was organizing, right?
They're doing, this is
stuff they're doing also
in their spare time.
And so, sometimes I'm nervous
that people who care about freedom
and justice think that they can only do
that through a specific career.
And it's like, "No, you need to be
a part of a political organization,
or figure out how to support one."
That's how we build and sustain movements
for the long term.
And I'm nervous about the decline of that,
especially as I look at what's happening
with progressives on the left,
it's like everyone is doing this through
their policy job.
And no one's doing this
through political struggle.
And even though we hear 20 million people
were pouring into the
streets for a protest,
that's cool, but 20 million people
did not get absorbed into organizations.
- Mm.
- 20 million people are not outside
the White House when Biden says,
"I'm gonna gonna keep choosing
to refund the police."
20 million people are not outside
of Rikers saying, let these people out,
'cause they're dying rapidly.
And so, that energy that
we get excited about
when we get those glimpses,
that gets called a movement,
but movements require so
much more sustainability
and organizing then those moments.
And so, we need people and I now,
I'm like, this is like alter call.
We need people to join organizations,
or at least to figure out
how to support them so we can fight
and build something much more sustainable.
- [Elizabeth] Right, thank you.
Thank you all for that, and
thanks for that, Derecka.
(group applauds)
I mean, and I think,
too I just wanna end it
on a historical lesson,
because that's what we see.
That's what sustained...
That's what sustained
the freedom movement historically.
- Yeah, yeah, yes.
It's been organizing,
it's been sustaining it.
It's been not just mass mobilizations.
Okay, so I wanna...
I have a million more questions,
but we're running out of time.
So, I really wanna open
it up to everyone else.
So, please start coming down
to the microphones to ask questions,
and while you do that, I'm
gonna pose one from online,
from Polly, and then, kind of tack one
of my own questions onto it.
So, Polly asked, "How
can we who have lived
our entire lives within empire,
create live inter political relationships
that don't replicate oppressive patterns?"
And I know that's a really,
really important, very broad question.
I would also kind of based on where
the conversation is headed, invite you
to also reflect on what universities
and what university
communities can and should do.
I mean, we're here at Yale University,
which just had an incident endowment
over the past year go up by $10 billion.
And yet, it gets...
The people of New Haven
basically (chuckles) subsidized Yale
at 160 million a year.
And 34% of the kids in New Haven are at,
or below the poverty level.
- Oh, my God.
- So, how can we think
about abolishing structures
that we are very much tied to and within?
From me and Polly.
- Well, I think, the last thing you said
was the answer was in the...
In the question, I mean, we have
just to talk about Yale, this is...
This is an old issue, and of
course, Yale's not unique,
but you have these land grant institutions
that don't pay taxes.
Where there's a intense
union struggle going on
all the time for living wage.
And I'm at a... And I teach at a school
where the basketball
coach, makes way more money
than anyone else.
And so, there's some basic things,
like if you think about reparations
and decolonization, take these two themes.
Reparations would mean that
those institutions like Yale,
that have been exploiting
people on stolen land
for three centuries owe something.
And so, if you include everything
that they've been able to extract
and to figure out a way
to sort of take that
and give it back, that's one thing,
and this is maybe a legal regime for that,
but decolonization is another thing.
In terms of the question
about how do you not
replicate oppressive systems,
something as basic as fighting
for indigenous sovereignty
can change a lot
of things in terms of
not just the environment,
but in terms of working
conditions, housing.
'Cause I'd much rather
be under sovereign rule
of indigenous peoples than I would under
the United States.
So, these are all opportunities,
and that basically means each one
of those things means two things.
It means the massive redistribution
of wealth and resources that
have been extracted and stolen.
And two, it means some complete
transformation of governance
and that may seem like pie in the sky,
but there's precedent for that.
I dunno if you...
- Why y'all looking at me, I don't know.
Well, (chuckles) just kidding.
Well, I... What can people
be doing at the university?
Well, I think, I wanna say organize,
we need people to organize.
I think, it's very exciting
when I see students and faculty
and staff organize together.
Another major lesson I
learned in South Africa
was just the students
and the staff struggle
were United for intentional reasons,
because staff were in precarious position.
They were being shifted
to becoming contractual laborers,
which means that they lost healthcare
and tuition benefits, and all the things
that you really fight for, fought for
to be a part of the university.
And so, those struggles are so important
and it makes me think
about the early formations
of the first black study
programs in the '60s.
Those black student
organizations that were forming,
they weren't forming for students,
anyone could kind of come
and be a part of them.
When they took over campus San
Francisco, State University,
those students, they went,
the black students and staff,
they went into the admission offices
and admitted black students,
because the university wouldn't
admit black students, right?
It's like, this is the context.
Sometimes I'm nervous
that because we don't
think about the length
that people went through
for political struggle,
the possibilities seem
like much more shallow.
I think it would be...
What would it look like for students here
to call for a moratorium?
Just a moratorium, just to say, "Hey,
let's stop for a second, let's pause
on expansion of Yale in New Haven."
It's a very... That's
a low hanging from...
That's not even all the way to me calling.
It seems like, hey, no more.
Yesterday, when I was leaving
the event last night, I
got into an Uber ride,
and the driver was playing T. Pain,
which was really nice.
It was, I felt warm and welcomed.
I was like, okay, this
is like, this is good.
And I just started asking her questions
about what it's like being in New Haven.
And she said, "Well, all
my friends are leaving,
'cause we can't afford
to live here no more.
And I was like, "Where
are they moving to?"
She didn't say New York.
She didn't say DC.
She said North Carolina,
South Carolina and Georgia.
And I said, "Is it because of the cost
of living that people keep
going further and further?"
She said, "Yeah," she said,
"You can't live around here."
And I was like, "Why not?"
And she said, I think she had just...
I think, she was probably
a police officer, or a security guard,
she had on her uniform.
She said, "I don't know, I hear activists
be using words like
gentrification, but I..."
I didn't know what gentrification was,
but in my entire life I knew
that it was happening, all right?
And I was like, "Oh, you
gotta join an organization."
Then I just started doing
my little organizing spiel
for her too.
(chuckles)
She was like, oh, maybe
that's not like my thing,
but people are gonna fight for it,
but Yale is just gonna win.
Yale is just gonna win.
And I was like, "Well you still gotta try,
we still gotta try."
So, when I see students trying
to do that, student, staff, faculty.
There are students right now
who are a student at Harvard over
their endowment because there's invested
in prisons and things that contribute
to fossil fuels.
I think, that's exciting.
I think, the Cops Off Campus Initiative,
I think, that was pretty exciting.
I think, people who are doing inside
and outside programs with people
who are incarcerated, I
think, that's important.
I think, yeah, I think
that that's all enough.
I think, I mean, I don't
think that's enough.
I think, those a good starts,
but I really do think it's gonna depend
on what inspired you to get activated
and doing that political education
with other people to figure out, okay,
what's the long term goal?
I'm gonna say this really quickly,
but Garrett, I keep
thinking about what you say,
Yale wouldn't be Yale.
And before we split that student group,
I was talking about
when we were reconfiguring our demands,
and we said, "We need to rethink
our admissions policy."
We need to rethink
tuition, all this stuff.
And one of the students said,
"Well, would this even be Harvard
if we had open admissions?"
- Right.
- And had such a fear of losing status,
and we were fighting
for again, very low hanging fruit.
We wanted the shield of Harvard Law
to change because it belonged to a family
that bequeathed money to
start Harvard Law School,
that got that money, 'cause
he was a slaver, right?
Fled during the revolutionary war,
but gave the money to Harvard Law School.
And when people, when we fought
to even get a shield change, a picture
that wasn't even that cute.
It wasn't even that cute.
(audience chuckles)
But there were alum, including black alum,
who said, "Oh, is my degree gonna mean
the same thing?"
Is my diploma gonna mean the same thing
if you guys get a new shield?
- Yeah.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, come on.
And then, our professors,
what did they say?
Well, if we want to change the shield,
then if you carry that line on through,
we're just gonna have to change all
the symbols in the United States.
(audience chatters and laughs)
I said, "Is that a critique or a plan?"
(group laughs)
'Cause that's our plan.
I said, "Yeah."
- Yeah, why not?
- Yeah, why not? I said,
"This sounds good."
I was like, "You trying to come
to the meeting on Thursday?"
(audience laughs)
Right, and so, there's
a deep fear of loss.
And that deep fear of loss is
being conflated with erasure
and protecting history.
And we have to say, no,
this is decolonization.
And we have to figure out how
to build more systemic
movement to name that.
We can affirm the loss for some people,
we can't say just because you afraid
of losing status, that this
is not worth the fight.
- Mm-hmm, that's right.
- Let's take a question from the audience,
from Nasar, who's a student
in my Afghan student class.
Thank you for being the first.
(group laughs)
- Peace, family.
So, yeah, Nasar in
Professor Hinton's class.
And I really enjoyed the panel.
Thank you everyone for coming
(mumbles indistinctly),
but I'm kind of involved with...
As a community organizer for
Black Lives Matter Patterson,
and we're really heavily involved
with the mutual aid that
you guys talking about.
We were very thankful,
but like every Friday,
we go out in the community, right?
Police ridden, mass incarceration,
just the violence is there.
And giving, it's much
more than giving food.
It's also about telling stories,
and joy, and laughter, right?
And so, it really is
like a movement of love
at the basis, which is at the center
for my opinion, of the political education
that we're getting at.
But maybe in your experiences,
both with research and
on the streets activism,
what do you think the role is
in the importance of love and building
that in the abolitionist movement?
- Such a good question (indistinct).
- I mean, Rodney, yeah, I mean...
(male chuckles)
It's at the center,
I think, is what... I mean,
that's like Robin's article
that I mentioned earlier,
"Love Study Struggle."
- [Robin] Mm-hmm.
- And I just think that love
is related to trust and relationships,
which are at the core of
struggle and organizing.
And I think, another component maybe
that I'll just push out
there that's related
to love is about commitment.
And I don't mean commitment
to a set of principles, but a commitment
to people to be around and to not dip in
and dip out.
That you have to maintain
lifelong relationships
with people and that love
can sound really good,
and it can also be really hard.
- [Derecka] Mm-hmm.
- [Robin] Right.
- Right, and we think
about how hard love is in our families,
or our intimate relationships,
but political love for long periods
of time can be really hard.
I mean, people hurt each other.
People betray each other.
So, I think, if that's not at the core
of the organizing that we do,
it can fall apart really fast.
And there's that energy
when you start organizing
and you feel like there's
love, and all this stuff,
and it can get really tough fast, I think.
Once you enter a kind
of period of maturity.
- Right.
- And I would also add this,
there's three kinds of love.
There's eros, which
we sometimes conflate with love.
There's philos, which is friendship,
and then there's agape.
So, when I talk about love
and I think, a lot of us talk about love,
we're thinking in terms of agape,
which Dr. King is drawing on people to it.
Calls the constant, relentless struggle
to make community, and no distinction
between friend and enemy.
That's the hardest thing.
Now, we may know who, what forces
were right against and that's different.
But the idea is that you try to create
a community that is completely inclusive.
And even the people that
you don't agree with,
you pull them in, not for consensus,
'cause it's not about consensus.
It's about constant
struggle to make community,
which means that you debate, you struggle,
you fight, you critique
until you could come
to a place of agreement,
which we know is always temporary.
So, just like Garrett was saying,
it's very, very hard
to do, but you can't...
There's no such thing as
a movement without love.
I mean, the irony is that even the Klan,
they operate on a basis of really demonic
kind of love.
(Derecka and audience chuckle)
And it's about, it's not even on the map,
that kind of love, but it's vicious.
- Yeah, I agree. I agree.
It's definitely been what Robin
just said about the constant struggle
to build community and a better society
for the people who may even disagree
with you, or who may hate you,
or may not dislike you.
It's yes, it's hard, so much so.
I actually, chapter four in the book
is called love and
abolition for that reason.
'Cause I care deeply about what
that struggle takes.
And I try to show this is where I talk
about that split in the student movement
and how hard that was.
This is where I talk about representing
a client that I had, who was very,
very racist toward me,
and toward other people, right?
And I had to stand next to this person
in court and vigorously defend
that person, right?
This is where I talk about
the black reconstruction and how Du Bois
sort of focuses on abolitionist,
primarily why abolitionist
is in the critique
of Du Bois for missing out
the deep revolutionary love and practices.
That black insurrection did to flee,
and build communities in the face
of white supremacist violence.
And so, I think, love
has an essential place,
and I hope my comments about mutual aid,
I'm hearing what you're saying.
I'm not anti-mutual aid.
I am very pro mutual aid.
I heart mutual aid, very, very big.
(audience laughs)
In the book, I affirm mutual aid.
And I said, "I think, it's
very, very important."
I think, one of my earlier comments,
what I was saying is that I'm nervous that
there's a shift I'm
experiencing among my peers,
and people who are
actually younger than me
to mutual aid, out of
desperation and pessimism.
Which is not the same as shifting
to it out of love.
So, I have a lot of
love for BLM Patterson.
I think, that's yo, Zoey, the whole crew.
I think y'all are doing...
Exactly, I know. I know, see?
(audience chuckles)
I think, that work is very important.
The free refrigerators
where people can come get food.
I get it, I know we
have to keep doing that.
I don't think Zoey and everyone there
is organizing from that place, right?
But I'm nervous about that becoming
a widespread thing, that's all.
- [Nasar] Thank you.
- Yeah, no, I knew D.G.
I know he looks surprised. (laughs)
(Elizabeth laughs)
- [Female] (mumbles) hello, everyone.
Hi, I have a question
from a comrade inside, actually.
- Oh, great.
- I don't know if the mic is on.
- [Female] Oh, is it not? Okay, oh.
- [Male] Yeah, maybe it turned off.
- Do I have to press something?
Is the microphone on?
(female chatters indistinctly)
- Maybe this one?
- Wanna use this mic?
You wanna just...
- (chuckles) sorry, yeah.
- There's also a mic here.
- I'm just thinking for
the people online too.
Yeah, I'm worse with technology, trust me.
(female chatters indistinctly)
(Elizabeth and Derecka chuckle)
- No, no, no, that's not a microphone-
- That microphone-
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
- Oh.
- Broken, wait, is this on?
(male chatters indistinctly)
Okay.
- Okay, (chuckles) sorry.
(panelists chatter indistinctly)
(group chuckles)
Sorry, that was my fault.
- Okay, all right.
Okay, is this...
- Yeah, that's much better, yeah.
- Wow, amazing, okay, thank you.
Hi, everyone, I have a question
from a comrade inside.
I mean, I also have a question of my own,
but I think, this is more important.
So, if y'all could just
kind of speak slowly when you answer,
if we're gonna try
to kind of write down your response,
that would be really helpful.
So, this is technically for Derecka.
I think, it can work for anyone.
It says, "Hello, Derecka Purnell,
I'm a prisoner in Texas
and I received a copy
of your book through No Name Books in L.A.
I became politicized in 2017
through contact with Black and Pink,
who you mentioned in your book.
It's been my observation
that the abolition community is made up
of a vast number of diverse collectives.
And I was wondering if
you had any suggestions
as to how these various collectives
can communicate with each other,
and become aware of each other,
so we can organize as a whole.
- That's so cool, that's a...
I'm at least familiar with
the collections and coalitions
among abolitionist organizations
is how actually, I came to learn
about a lot of abolish organizations,
because I'm a part of
groups and collectives,
and convenings where people are trying
to figure out how to align our work.
And so, those aren't typically broadcast,
or public, but they happen.
They happen regularly.
The last one I actually
organized was in 2000...
2020 was the last thing
I did before the pandemic.
And it was a convening
on police abolition.
And we had no idea
that seven months later, defund the police
would be the primary
demand from the streets.
We just didn't know, 'cause this was,
it was actually a sad weekend
this weekend, Kobe Bryant died.
That weekend was so transformational
and so memorable for lots
of different reasons.
But, in that convening,
there were maybe...
There were dozens of organizations there,
maybe 100 people who
were trying to figure out
our lines of difference,
and how to build coalition.
And I know critical resistances
had conveniences of people
doing abolitionist work.
MUMI was also incredible.
One of the last abolitionist
convenings that I attended.
I think that what's...
That I don't know if the person
who was asking that question is asking
for something that feels
like a United front.
Yeah, I want to say that, I think, any
of those number of people who
I write about in the book,
they know about the other
stuff that's going on.
And so, I don't know if it means
that it needs to be advertised better,
but most of those convenings
is except for the public one like you did,
or strategy convenings.
We're trying to figure out like, okay,
when people ask, what about the murders,
and what about sexual violence?
What's the work that's
happening in communities
to disrupt that, and
to help minimize that?
What are you guys doing
in your neighborhood,
how can we practice that
in our neighborhood?
And so, that is happening.
Fortunately, I would assume
that a lot of these people know.
I think that the thing
I'm actually concerned
about is whether the prison
police abolition folks
are actually missing out
on the socialism stuff.
There's like a... There's DSA over here
and abolitionist organizations over there.
And they're like sunrises in the middle.
(audience chuckles)
So, there's all these interesting,
important organizations
that are coming up,
and I'm nervous that their
politics are sort of insular
and wrapped around their particular thing.
And so, I've met, yeah,
I've met abolitionists.
People who claim they're abolitionist
and still hold onto capitalism.
I've met socialists who are
staunch anti-abolitionists.
So, trying to get people together,
think through our class analyses
and our colonial analyses is I think,
that work has to do a lot more.
I can give this to you
so you don't have to try
to type it all right now,
and then, I can also
make some recommendations
on where that person can start.
(audience chatters indistinctly)
- [Garrett] Yeah, can I just add to?
One, I think, we're gonna have
a transcript of this, so we can also...
That will be much easier.
- [Elizabeth] And we're recording a video.
- And to this question about, I mean,
this is sort of like
a call to action again
from the front, and some tangible ways
to get involved.
I think, so much of the work that has
to be done across walls is between us
and people inside.
But then, there's this other barrier too,
I think, collective
dreaming and organizing,
which is people inside between, right?
And like the gender segregation,
that happens in prisons.
I mean, the organizing that happens
in different prisons is different.
And so, one of the things
that we've been trying to do
with Study and Struggle is really act
as facilitators outside so people inside
can share organizing with each other.
So, that's part of why
we produce transcripts
and send them inside, and have panels
with incarcerated people
from different states.
And then, produce a transcript of that
to send to other states.
And this is not new work.
I mean, I don't know if folks are familiar
with Yuri Kochiyama, but I've been talking
to political prisoners from that era.
And they talk about writing people inside.
And I was like, "Oh, and back in the day,
you could write to people on the inside?"
And they were like, "No, I wrote to Yuri,
and then she sent..."
So, there's these interlocutors outside
and it's, I'm not...
I mean, this is not sexy work.
This is painstaking unseen labor,
but to be the people
who are facilitating those relationships,
because then people inside don't have
to constantly, in
isolation from one another,
invent and reinvent these things.
I just think so much of what
the prison is doing is that isolation,
and it's not just a geographic separation.
It's a barrier to the collective knowledge
that we all have, and did have.
- Yeah, can I give one
quick example about that?
- Yes.
- Just to make it very, very clear,
in many states, if not all states,
if you try to start a petition,
you can get into solitary confinement.
And a petition is anything that has more
than one signature.
And so, there's like organizations
like fight toxic prisons,
who work with people
who are inside to do
one signature petitions,
'cause that's how they
have to build momentum
for their cause.
When you talk about
fascism inside of prisons,
if you try to do something as simple
as get two, or three, 10 signatures,
try to organize in the wing.
You're trying to start it riot,
you're trying to (mumbles indistinctly).
So, this is the importance of,
I just wanted to illustrate that,
cause that to me is one of the examples
that make it so bright.
- And can I say one more thing?
So much of the work we do outside
is online exclusively.
People inside have no
way of accessing that,
which is obvious to say,
but to the extent that you can create
a sort of printable
version of that for people.
Like I constantly just
find myself emailing people
and like, "Was there a transcript?
Is there a PDF?"
I'm like copying and pasting websites
into Word documents, and sending them.
So, I just think, we need to be cognizant
of how that is a barrier
for people who are organizing.
- Thank you so much for that.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for that question.
- Do you wanna...
Did you wanna ask your question, or...
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
- Oh, okay.
- Okay.
- Okay, all right, cool.
Thanks (indistinct).
Okay, my...
Okay, this is on, right?
Okay, yeah, cool, all right.
Okay, my other question
is that I think there's a lot
of appreciable tension and movement work
between legal and extra legal action.
I guess, this is kind of pushing
a little bit more on the question
that you asked previously.
I think, a lot of folks inside
sometimes do emphasize
kind of legal action
just for, I don't know, small things.
Like I don't wanna cut my hair
and things like that.
In this vein, how would
you define non-reformist reforms,
and what place, if any, do you think
they have in movement work?
- You used the term you don't want to.
- Mm-hmm, no, you're right
about this right now,
so it's all good.
- About non reformist reforms.
- No, about-
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
- About using that.
- But yeah.
- Yeah.
- (sighs) Okay, so I'll take...
I mean, so I'm right, yeah.
- Let me throw this question in there too-
- Okay.
- From online, just 'cause
we're running out of time.
And I think, it's on a related point
from that question and just
the discussion in general.
And it comes from someone Benehoff online,
and it says, "Comrades inside
are often struggling to survive
the imminent threats and
slow death of prison.
How do we bridge the gap
between survival and politics?"
And then, this is another one
I'm just gonna throw out.
Throwing a lot out there.
Alternatively, would y'all mind speaking
a bit about the dialectic
between the struggle
to survive incarceration
and the development
of the abolitionist movement?
(audience laughs)
- I see what you did there. (laughs)
(Derecka laughs)
Okay, I'll take a piece.
- Okay.
- Okay, so...
- There's a way you can weight it all.
- Yeah, I mean, I think, this gets back
to the question about law
and abolition in a way.
And it's just that, so Derecka
very carefully crafted the difference
between the use of law,
and being a lawyer,
and an abolitionist.
Like a vocational sort
of careerist version,
versus the tool of law.
And I think, that goes for a lot
of different things.
Which is that I don't think we can afford
to leave any tools on the table, right?
These are all potentially subversive tools
if used appropriately.
And that doesn't mean
that they're not dangerous tools
that can wind up being reforms,
and therefore, fascist.
But yeah, I mean, I'm writing about
a person who is a revolutionary anarchist,
and a jailhouse lawyer,
and used constitutional law to...
To mitigate the circumstances
that he was organizing in.
I mean, he was at one point
in solitary confinement,
unable to communicate
with a single person besides his lawyer.
So, there, the law is both,
the sort of only gateway
to the outside world,
and he knew how to write a writ
that wound up in Constance
Baker Motley's court
and got him out of solitary.
So, he could do other things
like write a revolutionary newspaper,
and organize a chapter of
the Black Panther Party.
So, it's, I think, that
kind of relationship of,
I mean he wasn't thinking
like this constitution
that's so sacrosanct
will abolish the state.
But that was a... That was
basically the only tool available
to him, really.
So, I think, that's my
answer to that question.
- Oh no, go ahead.
- No, you can go, so go ahead.
- You know more than me.
Well, I'm only gonna say one thing
about the law,
(group chuckles)
which may not answer the question,
but just because I've been...
I'm writing something on
Mutulu Shakur right now,
and trying desperately to get him out.
And Mutulu has been in
prison for a long time,
precisely because when
he got law up in 1986,
he and others made the case
that they are prisoners of war.
In other words, they turned
to international law,
international courts
and Geneva Conventions.
And that's, so the federal courts,
they hate that, the judge hates that.
And so his mandatory parole had passed,
and he's still locked up,
had COVID, still locked up.
So, I think, that there's something
to say just for those of
you who are interested,
to look at international law,
to look at that as an option.
To look at what it means
to be a prisoner of war, trying to fight
for justice and that
there's certain protections
that prisoners of war
are supposed to have,
in the United States, or elsewhere.
So, that's just one area of the law
we don't always think about,
that's not necessarily reformist reform,
but Derecka knows more than me.
- (chuckles) What was the part
of the last question online?
Bridge the gap.
- About survival.
- [Elizabeth] Yeah, how
do we bridge the gap
between survival and politics,
and yeah, we'll just say that.
- But wait, no, what was the second part,
'cause that was the part-
- The second part was,
"Would y'all mind speaking
a bit about the dialectic
between the struggle
to survive incarceration,
and the development
of the abolitionist movement?"
- Yeah, so I was...
A similar point came up earlier today
in the conversation I was
having about abolition,
and the way that the
person sort of framed it,
it was as if the abolitionists
are outside talking about abolitionist,
doing abolitionist organizing.
And there are people who
are incarcerated dealing
with the real realities of the prison.
And they don't have time for
the abolitionist stuff outside,
because they need access to food.
They need access to water.
All of this, they experience overcrowding.
And what I...
How can I say this?
The bridge is there,
the work comes from that bridge, right?
Because most of the people,
at least the tradition,
I hope that I belong to that.
I see myself belong to the...
For 40 years, at least, of
riotings and organizing around
the prison industrial complex.
So much of that direction has come
from the people inside.
It's like... But for their organizing,
their rebellions, their uprisings,
I think, that has given rise
to the prison abolition movement outside
of prisons, right?
And so, you're talking about
Angela Davis speaking in 1994,
and speaking from someone
who was once a political prisoner, right?
And so, that it's...
It's not like how do we get
this to reach each other,
but so much of that survivor
work, that risk taking,
that then informs the struggle
that takes place outside.
And I wanna emphasize
that, so, so, so much,
'cause we're in an era
where there's this thing
around deference politics.
Like you defer to people who
are directly impacted, right?
But the people who they want you
to defer to, who are directly impacted
are people who they decide.
And usually, people who want to maintain
the power of prisons.
- Mm-hmm.
- Right, I've never seen at
philanthropy conferences,
abolition has directly
impacted people, or survivors.
The type of survivors that people
in the mainstream choose to uplift.
We need to be listening to
these kinds of black women,
but they're not black women
abolitionist survivors, right?
And so, I think, what's important for us
to always name and to explain is that
so much of our grassroot organizing,
so much of what makes it
into the halls at Harvard,
and to Yale has first been theorized
and organized around people
who experienced the oppression.
- Right.
- That that is true of radical politics.
That is very, very, very, very true,
and we must not forget that.
And so, when I hear
critiques of abolition being
an academic exercise, I'm like,
"Oh wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
let's go back 40 years ago
before the uprising in 2020."
Let's read the works of people,
let's look at the demands
of prisoners doing these rebellions.
- Mm-hmm.
- Yes, they were asking for more freedoms,
they were also asking to be free, right?
They were asking for better food
and a right to healthcare,
'cause they didn't wanna die
and suffer until they're released.
Right, but they also
demanded to close prisons.
Nas didn't say, if I ruled the world,
I would free all nonviolent offenders.
(group laughs and claps)
Not in my version.
Did you hear that?
I didn't, did Lauren seen that on her...
I didn't hear that version-
- That's probably the clean version.
- He said, "I free all my sons, all, all."
- Mm-hmm.
- Take 'em outta Atticus,
send them to Africa,
that's the version I heard.
So, it's like, it's so much.
You asked about culture earlier.
It's so much in our culture, 'cause again,
we learned that based on our experiences.
And so, it doesn't make us experts,
hopefully just helps keep
us within that tradition.
- Yeah, yeah, and by the way,
the anti-Klan movement started in prison,
you know that right?
The anti-Klan movement
in 1980s began in prison
with prisoners, who
were fighting the Klan,
who were hired as guards and wardens.
And we forget that.
We think that somehow all these movements
are on the outside in
that on the inside people
are not fighting those same fights.
This is a perfect example.
(crosstalk drowns out speaker)
- Go for it, yeah.
- [Male] Hello, thank you so much
for all being here.
When I heard that there was a panel
with all of you on it, I was like,
how did you (laughs) get this many
of the people who I admire,
and that their fields of scholarship one
to one, (chuckles) one desk.
But I was really interested actually,
and I feel like it's been a theme
throughout everything
that you all have said.
At the beginning, both,
sorry what was the name
of the first of the two
people inside that you...
Was it...
- Oh, Lawrence.
- Lawrence.
- Yeah.
- Where sort of, Lawrence was saying,
look mutual aid is great and all,
but we're not...
We also have to keep in mind
sort of fighting to actually
end these structures.
And I feel like there's
a disconnect that I see
because I grew up fairly politicized,
but I became an organizer
during the rebellions
around Mike Brown and
Eric Garner in New York.
And I feel like ever since that moment,
I've just seen a disconnect
between both what happens
in organizing spaces,
and in movement spaces of protest.
And then, an even bigger disconnect
between what happens in these spaces,
and what's happening in the streets.
And I feel like it's so poignant
in so many places.
I don't wanna go into to details,
but I've seen people
who call themselves organizers, fighting
to control the sort of,
in their eyes, destructive like (mumbles),
like destructive impulses
of people who are just like, okay,
these tops are screwing with us every day.
I have friends inside.
I want to burn this police
station to the ground.
And they're like, "No, don't do that,
we're nonviolent," right?
And obviously like,
this is an exaggeration
of what some people are on.
And then you get to here, and I think,
you think about the difference
between the uprisings
at Mizu that happened
in 2015, and what happened here.
It was like, at Mizu, the first thing
they were talking about
was their connections
to Ferguson, 'cause it was so close.
And here, you try to
mention police brutality
and everyone was like,
you're gonna destroy
our movement. (chuckles)
And like, muddying the waters.
And so, I guess, in terms of both of these
kinds of disconnects, I do think
that there is a really important role
of those of us, who maybe have put
a lot of premium on...
Who have existed in a lot
of these spaces in movements.
But I guess, I wonder how do you build
those kinds of long term,
sort of movement to destroy these systems
that you're talking about?
How do you, sort of bridge those gaps?
Because what you were saying earlier
about like, okay,
you have 12 million
people out on the streets,
but you don't see them in front
of the White House.
I think that the flip side of that right,
is that everybody is like, "Oh, well,
what you're doing is just spontaneous,
you gotta get organized."
And then, people are
like, "Okay, so what do
I do to get organized?"
And they're like,
"Follow us on Instagram."
(audience chuckles)
Come out to campaign for this politician.
And they're like, "Well,
that's not what we want.
We were here to destroy the police."
And so, I guess, obviously,
I know that a lot...
Not to say this radical work
isn't happening, and I'm not asking for...
I'm sure there are plenty of people
in this room who know
about some of this work.
And I'm not asking to
Henry Box Brown anyone,
but I guess, if you have some
sort of, in the perhaps,
slightly more abstract,
how to actually create the culture
of sort of destruction
of policing and prisons,
and take those cues from inside
where people would say,
abolition, nothing less.
- And you have one minute.
- Sorry.
- To answer those,
to answer that big question.
- One minute.
- I'm not gonna answer the question,
but I will say that everything
that she just described is old.
(group laughs)
No, no I'm saying it's not new.
That's not a critique.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
- What I'm saying is that this has been,
you go back to mass mobilizations,
versus what SNCC is doing in Mississippi.
- Mm-hmm.
- You count the number of people
who are organizing the SNCC is very small.
You count the people who
show up in Washington DC
on August 28th, it's large.
You think about all the divisions,
sometimes with divisions
around social economic issues.
Sometimes divisions around anti communism.
So, it's like the difference of course,
is social media and other strategies,
but I'm saying, this is the age old issue.
And I'm sure that both Garrett and Derecka
have some solutions to that age old issue.
(group laughs)
- I'll just say no, I'll just say briefly,
I do think that to say kind of the point
that Derecka shared earlier about
the disagreement, or the sort of, lack
of clarity around what
we mean by abolition.
We do want a mass movement,
but I think, we do need to clarify.
I mean, that's why I really take
the task of defining abolition seriously
as a worthy...
'Cause I think, are we talking
about abolishing the state?
And a lot of people are not talking
about abolishing the state,
but then, how do we imagine
a state existing without
police and prisons?
I don't think that could exist,
but people clearly do, 'cause they're not-
- Oh, Garrett's an anarchist, this is new,
I didn't know this.
(audience laughs)
(speaker drowned out by laughter)
This is spicy, I wasn't ready. (laughs)
(group laughs)
- Anyway, no so I just think,
we need more space to really hash out
what we're talking about.
Are we talking about
abolition and capitalism?
I didn't know what we were talking
about that, so but no, I don't think
it's a thing to be resolved
as much like a contradiction to be lived.
- Right, Derecka, you have the last word.
- Last word, ooh, Jesus.
Okay, so I agree with a big
part of your assessment.
I wrote about this, actually in January
that I'm nervous that
with rise of social media,
what has happened with online organizing
is that we have organizers,
perhaps inadvertently have created
a like, share, subscribe culture.
And that's how people can get involved
in the movement, which
is very, very different
than come to this meeting, sit here
for three hours to do an orientation.
Can you offer this as a sacrifice
of your time, and your
labor, and of your talent.
So, I think, that organizers are trying
to figure out how to do mass absorption
with the rise of the internet.
And I think, it's very challenging,
and I've seen, and constantly working
through those challenges.
I think, it's similar also to
what I was saying earlier
about people channeling
our hopes and dreams
into specific career
ambitions on the left.
- Uh-huh.
- I'm very nervous about that.
I think, a similar thing
has happened too, around
how do we effectuate change?
And so, in the long time ago,
you would see these vibrant movements
to shut things down.
Like use all tactics for
revolutionary violence
to the law to figure it out.
Now, when something happens,
everyone gives money to the ACLU.
- Right.
- hen have the ACOU become the frontline?
No shade to the ACLU, not
really like no shade to ACLU.
(group laughs)
But they become like,
I don't know, the Che
Guevara, like (mumbles)...
(group laughs)
It's so wild.
I'm like, every time there's a crisis,
we're gonna take them to court.
And then, people give money
for them to go to court.
And it's like, yeah,
we need to go to court,
but we also need much
more mass mobilizations
and people entering to organizations
and finding political homes,
to figure out how to
answer these questions.
And so, I'm attracted to organizations
like the centers, who is trying to build
a youth movement to end militarism,
who's fighting to keep
ROTCs off of campuses.
- Yeah.
- Who's fighting against
the 1030 peace transfer programs,
who's trying to do deep
political organizing
around these issues.
And so, we have those examples that exist,
and that are engaging in
lots of different tactics,
and trying to figure out
how to absorb people,
to then effectuate that, right?
And so, I think the more we realize
the terrain where people now
are just donated to a
nonprofit, or people in the past
who didn't have political representation
that look like that.
So, now, you think you're fighting
a white supremacist structure,
that's keeping black people, or women out,
and now, we have more, the most amount
of diverse representation.
Three people are still being killed today
by the police.
More than a million black
people are still locked up.
Black women still have wealth of $5, like-
- Right.
- So, the political representation
through diversity is an
answer because who was it?
Like Fred Hampton said,
"We were saying white when we should
have been saying capitalist, all right?
We were our critiques for it,
like being lost in the wrong places.
And so, I think that we
absolutely need political homes.
We need organizations to really
think about the traditions
that get people off of
line and into seats.
And that's very hard, but it's something
that we just have to figure out and do.
- Mm-hmm.
(group applauds)
- Please join me...
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you all for just an incredible
and eye opening discussion.
- Yeah, thank you.
Thank you, Liz. Thank you so, so, so much.